Мене дивує, як і кожного в цьому залі, чому дівчинка, якій 32 роки,
яка пропрацювала в системі охорони здоров’я і ні дня, я сподіваюся, офіційно
не працювала в цій структурі, закликає нас проголосувати за один з дуже важливих документів.
Таке висловлювання з вуст депутата Верховної Ради Сергія Рудика на адресу парламентарки Мар’яни Безуглої
стало першим публічним проявом сексизму в стінах парламенту ІХ скликання.
За декілька днів до інциденту колеги Мар’яни по фракції "Слуга народу" зареєстрували законопроєкт,
який вперше юридично визначає поняття сексизму як дії чи слова, що виставляють людину гіршою
через її стать, зачіпають гідність, порушують права та завдають шкоди.
Нас уже поглинули скандали, якісь переписки, висловлювання, звинувачення.
Це увесь час відбувається. А я думаю, що якби за будь-які такі висловлювання була встановлена відповідальність,
це могли б бути навіть виправні роботи. І це було б цікаво, якби народний депутат за такі висловлювання
попідмітав би вулиці на Хрещатику чи якісь інші вулиці.
Якщо депутати підтримають законопроєкти авторства Олександра Качури,
то сексизм в Україні буде вперше офіційно заборонений. А ті, хто до нього вдаватимуться,
окрім виправних робіт, можуть бути оштрафовані на суму 1700-3400 гривень
чи навіть арештовані на 15 діб. Серед ініціаторів законопроєкту і депутат "Слуги народу" Олександр Корнієнко.
Свого часу він фігурував у гучному скандалі через те, що дозволив собі коментарі
у бік народної депутатки Ірини Алахвердієвої та бізнесвумен Тетяни Домбровської.
Коли діалог депутатів набув розголосу, Олександр Корнієнко спочатку відхрестився
від своїх слів, мовляв, трансляція змонтована. Але потім вибачився перед жінками,
яких обговорював. І тепер як член міжфракційного об’єдання депутатів "Рівні можливості"
й сам бореться з гендерними упередженнями.
Звичайно, бачите, я зробив висновки, це ж великий медійний розголос був,
багато довелося з цього приводу почути, почитати, ознайомитися,
поспілкуватися з колегами з інших країн, парламентарями. У принципі я ніколи не був противником того,
що такі теми треба піднімати в суспільстві і в законодавстві.
Ми працюємо над змінами до регламенту якраз, пов’язаними з покаранням депутатів за сексизм.
Однак депутати не єдині політики, що дозволяються собі сексистські висловлювання.
Неодноразово гендерно упереджені фрази лунали й з вуст президента Володимира Зеленського.
Хай жінка перша (скаже), це правильно. Та почекайте, ви ж не жінка, ви серйозна людина.
Під час офіційного візиту до Парижа в червні 2019 року Зеленський сказав,
що красиві українські жінки залишаються "нашим брендом".
А спікер парламенту  Дмитро Разумков, щоправда, ще до свого призначення,
порівняв Верховну Раду зі зґвалтованою дівчиною.
Депутатка партії "Голос" Інна Совсун запевняє: ті випадки сексизму, що стають публічними,
лише верхівка айсберга. Адже парламентарі часто вдаються до гендерно упереджених жартів
і коментарів  у робочих чатах, на засіданнях комітетів та у неформальному спілкуванні.
Тому, на її думку, законотворче регулювання сексизму вже давно назріло в Україні.
Однак Совсун вважає доцільним розрізнити типи сексистських висловлювань
і передбачити за них різне покарання.
Саме тому у Верховній Раді зареєстрували ще один альтернативний законопроєкт,
що враховує ці нюанси.
Є сексистські висловлювання, які, вочевидь, обмежують твою можливість
реалізовувати свої права. До прикладу, якщо тебе не слухають на комітеті ВР,
тому що ти "дєвчонка-хохотушка" або "женщина, яка вносить сумятицу"
або ж "32-річна дівчинка", то це вже не просто образа, а образа,
яка обмежує твою професійну діяльність. І вочевидь, що в такому випадку дійсно треба реагувати жорсткіше.
Тому я би казала, що ось ці речі треба розрізнити на рівні законодавства.
Бо якщо ми порівняємо неспівмірні речі між собою,
то ми можемо отримати закон, який не працюватиме.
Тим часом жіночі громадські й правозахисні організації очікують від закону
не тільки поступового викоріннення сексизму, але й зменшення загальної дискримінації жінок у владі
на всіх рівнях. Адже попри рекордні для України 20 відсотків депутаток
у парламенті 9-го скликання, це все ще менше від європейської практики.
В уряді й поготів - лише 3 міністерки жіночої статі.
Жодна жінка не обіймає посаду міського голови в обласних центрах.
Такі існують упередження, що політика - це не жіноча справа.
Під час виборів жінкам часто закидали, що жінка не може бути меркою, баба не може бути мером.
Або посилали йти варити борщі, бо політика, мовляв, не жіноча справа. Ми очікували цих змін.
І ще на початку виборчої кампанії ми розуміли, що в нас не буде можливості
звертатися до правоохоронних органів, щоби фіксувати сексизм,
бо такого явища в українському законодавстві досі немає. І я більш ніж переконана,
що жіночі громадські організації візьмуть цю справу
у свої руки і почнуть користуватися цим законодавством.
А поки антисексистські  законопроєкти чекають на розгляд у Верховній Раді,
гендерні експертки й депутатки радять не зволікати і реагувати на сексизм
щонайменше зауваженнями, якщо йдеться про побутові ситуації,
або ж розголосом у випадку публічних образ.
Коли таке трапляється, не можна мовчати, не можна не відреагувати.
Бо якщо ти один раз не відреагуєш, це дозвіл повторювати такі жарти чи невдалі коментарі,
чи образливі висловлювання в майбутньому. Це складно, я вам скажу з особистого досвіду.
Значно простіше змовчати, посміхнутися, перейти до обговорення по суті.
Але тим самим ми підводимо не тільки себе, ми підводимо мільйони українських жінок,
які вимушені терпіти такі ж висловлювання часто в значно гірших формах.
Тому депутати з різних фракцій звернулися до Сергія Рудика з вимогою вибачитися
за сексистські й ейджистські висловлювання, сказані ним минулого тижня в трибуни Верховної Ради.
Але давайте скажемо чесно. Пан Рудик, безперечно, не вважає, що народні депутати
не мають права висловлюватися. Його подив викликає, що говорити може жінка,
особливо якщо їй 32 роки. Дозволю собі нагадати пану Рудику,
що жінки у 32 роки можуть мати значно більші досягнення, ніж окремі чоловіки.
У відповідь на звернення колег Сергій Рудик не вибачився, а лише процитував власний блог,
сповнений гендерних кліше, чим ще раз підкреслив необхідність
визначення самого поняття "сексизм" та механізмів покарання за його використання.
Після прийняття антисексистських законів скаржитися за гендерно некоректні вислови
чи поведінку можна буде до поліції, місцевим органам самоврядування
чи навіть уповноваженому з прав людини.